the board and then he moves now well  this is a nice little trick for wei you  know  rook takes pawn threatened  yeah how do you stop this that's the  question yeah okay i mean worse comes to  worse you just push your pawn one square  forward i think that's winning and uh  some tactics that we will explain a bit  later  but  now if white makes a new queen the  problem is black's rook comes across  takes a pawn with a check  and you can't keep your queen on the  board  wow he defends it with his rook is that  a good move i  think so  but you have to calculate and i think  it's a very good move now no matter what  happens i think white is about to make a  new queen you can't stop white making a  new queen black's pawn remember is still  covered by the white rook  and way head in his hands yeah he's  going to resign and you can tell  body language there and there there we  go we have the result  wow  after 78 moves and another game lasting  more than an hour pregnant on that wins  another